hello everyone this is hello everyone
this is secret life of what okay take
two hello everyone I'm Dennis Bush this
is the first class of secret life of
pons the soul of the game today I'm
going to talk about a spawns or pastures
that we like to say and the first
example will be a classic example later
examples will kind of be a detour from
that so the first example is between
Levon Aronian and Vishwanathan Anand
Anand who just again recently won the
rapid were a championship in which we
give hearty congratulations because
that's a huge result as he was the world
champion in previous years but this is a
huge comeback anyways this game between
Aronian and Anand will show how to
create pass pawns in the classical way
so d4 d5 c4 c6 can anybody tell me what
opening is this yes it's the Queen's
Gambit yeah and there's more specific
the slop yes Knight a three-night of six
and in general but have white has a
troubled history here it's difficult to
get an advantage here they tried a three
they tried Knight c3 which is the main
line but Iranian tried to deviate from
all theory and played Queen C to D takes
e4 Queen takes e4 in fact this is still
a variation but a much more rare one
Bishop a5 g 397 everyone's just
developing their pieces castle rook e1
now just for educational reasons i want
to point out that rook d1 would be a
huge blunder here how could black
possibly punish
this overeager move rook do you want
hint it has to do with the strange but
quite awkward nature of the Queen c4p
non-si for there is no such a thing as a
bad idea
yep yep Bishop c2 indeed
so now what is forced to move the rook
let's say Rudy - that makes the most
sense
and even though your bishop is attacked
let's see if the Queen can actually move
right now
not really
so the move had be six indeed and now
this hits the Queen and it went sit to
because all these important squares on
d3 and b3 are covered especially because
of this healthy bishop on c2 so that's
something we don't want to fall for and
Levin didn't fall for that one then
played rookie 194 Queen b3 Queen b6 and
not h4 now this was a huge novelty at
the time in 2007 and they played it for
years but I guess around 2010 they
stopped playing it Bishop h4g takes h4
now black has a better structure because
this is very ugly but as a main subject
our onion is aiming to get the bishop
pair for it and also a hope to get a
passport not of 6e for bishop g6 and in
general when you're trying to get a past
form they usually work when it's an
endgame
so obviously Aronian took on b68 xv6
Bishop f4 which pawn break is white
aiming for in this position
they're not many available in this
position but there's still one yep
well we have kind of a dampened Bishop
on g2 so we want to activate it somehow
d5 yeah the idea is to go and try to
break through with d5 yes sir rook e8
book d1 b5 Bishop d6 Aronian is
preparing this idea of d5 while stopping
any kind of beef or ideas for black so
what Aronian is playing for his
restriction just kind of annoying for
Anand as his pieces hardly have any
squares to move to e5 d5 and now comes
the d5 move we have been waiting for
Knight h5 Bishop f1 now the sad part for
black is that these pawns are too rigid
on the Queen side the c6 pawn cannot
really take here which it would like to
do because then we could take the b5
pawn so I have 6 on on this force to be
passive in this position B 3 B 3 is a
very nice move and it's also indicating
another break another way of pawn
breaking and that is the move a
four-night at 4400 comes B takes a 4 B
takes a 4 why did why take with the be
pawn instead of the night
strategically what's the idea of B takes
a 4
can you yeah yeah to have a pastor maybe
potentially yeah and yet you had an idea
yeah indeed the knight on c3 is very
useful as it does protect all three
pawns and the third reason is why
desperately would like to put the rook
on b1 and just hit on the b7 pawn so
Aronian is trying to conjure up more and
more advantage in this position which is
difficult if the position stays closed
so he opens it up B takes a 4 B takes a
for Bishop f7 rugby 1 and also when you
attack your opponent's pawn structure
you force their hands they have to
decide either they going to have to
defend them passively or have to make a
resolution route k7 Anand decides to
wait passively rogue d1 butter onion is
also patient
he just bolsters this d5 pawn which is
about to become a passed pawn rook c8 92
Knight éxito Bishop take C to C takes it
takes d5 so we can point out the passed
pawn in this position which is which one
which pawn yep the d5 pawn and with two
two great bishops on d6 + e2 why it
should have a huge advantage but still
there needs to be some precision to
convert it 9 f8 now rook takes a 420
rook takes b7 and also sometimes ideas
with Bishop b5 might happen even though
there's now rook g4 check so not a fate
this should be 5 defending everything
and now what is it very good position
but you still have to come up with a
constructive plan to actually win the
game what should I be aiming for
how could my nurse this spawn into a
queen what should be our long-term plan
using the bishops where should we put
this bishop on d6 yeah e 7 so Bishop e7
is a very very good idea and that's
actually well known from Greenfeld
structures when the bishop goes to e7
and the pawn push d6 comes as well why
it has a huge initiative then rook e8
Bishop e7 comes 96 d6 Knight takes a 7
and now Aronian comes up with a
brilliant idea so why to move and come
up with a fairly unusual tactical
solution
Bishop d7 yeah and now the main idea is
that if we take Black has an extra
defender here on C 8 and 8 but Aronian
wants to have just one defender there so
if the rook moves wouldn't move
somewhere let's say C 4 then D take C 7
and there's only one defender here and
after let's say Bishop e8 mo then it's
Bishop e6 check immediately winning so
it's already very uncomfortable for
black therefore Anand had no choice but
to accept the sacrifice and play 95
knight c6 that is takes on b7 as there's
no way of running away because if the
rook moves to d8 Bishop takes c6 the
same thing happens if Ruby 8 then we
just taken we are up a healthy pawn it's
an ID for Bishop takes c8 Queen rook
takes c8 and in general the bishop and
Knight is stronger than the rook but for
a good reason why this better what is
that reason that white is better here
the past pawns
exactly our topic the fast pawns that's
why why it is much better here and when
I was young people told me to exchange
of something that your opponent has and
you don't have so Aronian decides to go
rugby one threatening the rook b8 which
is unfortunately for analysis it's not
possible to stop and after that there
won't be a rook to stop these pawns from
marching so Rukia fade route b8
Bishop e8 a five-night that's rechecking
f 192 can you one notice that Aronian
consciously moves his Kings King to e1
and not e two because his sacrifice
wouldn't work as well as Knight takes B
1 and if you don't take the knight then
I could jump with a c3 check so not
qing-ge one is very important and I'd be
a six and now these two pastors are just
too strong so Bishop c6 a7 king f7 in
here our onion comes up with the deadly
move and wins the game
yeah d7 as the bishop on c6 is
overloaded it was already just
protecting this aid square so you cannot
just take now because we would take take
and queen
so King g7 rook takes effort and King
these seven Queens and soonerlater this
game was won by white as h5 bouquet
seven check and Aronian picked up
another pawn and then three more moves
undone resigned so this is the classical
way of creating past bonds I'm going to
show some of my games and a very
classical one by world champions where
you actually use a past bond in the
middle game so this is my first game
played in the LA cash Memorial and I
like this game because it specifically
shows how important is it is to create a
passport not of 6 e 5 this is called the
sveshnikov variation even though later
rationing of likes to claim this line to
be his which is called kalashnikov
Knight f6 Knight c3 e 5 not BC my DB v
d6 Bishop g5 a 695 there's also a move
with Bishop takes f6 G takes Knight d5
Bishop g7 C 3 with long long variations
but I went 95 Bishop e7 takes takes c3
would be eight ball stirring this b5
pawn Knight c2 Bishop g5 Bishop e2 just
developing 97 94 well in these type of
positions the fight is revolving around
this D
I've Square whoever has control over
that has the better position at this
moment me Bishop b7 and what is kind of
natural in these threatening of
positions that might needs to play
energetically to actually claim an
advantage so I'd ask you to find a move
for a white which keeps the initiative
and give some hope for white for an
advantage it's white to move here well
it's easy to notice that most of the
weaknesses for black is on white squares
so the d5 square is extremely weak from
blacks perspective these squares are
kind of loosey-goosey so how could we
use the fact that these squares are
extremely weak
yeah c6 1 c4 c4 the idea is good but the
problem that you would weaken this
diagonal also black to play a 5 but the
basic idea is good you want to undermine
the queenside right yeah
a4 exactly the idea is if a 5 now then I
could take on b5 a check but c4 I
couldn't do that because I blocked the
view of this Bishop I would just hit the
pawn so I can't do that
therefore I played a 4
Bishop takes d5 and here again comes a
question in with which piece should I
take it
I consider taking with the night but if
I take it with the night that will be
just the standard / neck of positions
where I might have a slight advantage
but not too much let's say ninety five
castles take stakes and I'm not sure
that white is so much better so I took a
slightly riskier approach with eat eggs
d5 but I realized something in this
position he has no other move than Queen
b6 if he plays a5
I wouldn't take on b5 because that will
run into Ruby 5 8 x + 8 eggs before and
my structure would look very bad with
this Irish pawn structure but I have
Knight a6 attacking the knight and upon
simultaneously and I would have been an
exchange so Queen b6 is the only move
and here I found a good solution which
gave me the advantage it's my to move
and
get a big advantage mm-hmm and if green
takes a sex mm-hmm Bishop takes me five
rook takes it yes exactly so I realized
that I have this wonderful sacrifice and
I get two pawns for the two pieces and a
rope for me so Queen takes v5 doesn't
work as you mentioned because of ruke
aide and I will have this awesome takes
on h8 there's no one who could defend
against that and have a great position
so Queen B 7 C for now the reason I'm
better here is that I have a bunch of
pawns one bunch of pawns here and also
the b5 is a protected passed pawn and
that will be the decisive one in this
game castles rue k-6
now I really like this rook a six move
in general when you have a useful move
before castling in professional and
high-level chests you try to get as much
you can get before castling so you try
to activate this rook first hitting on
d6 and just then castle because I might
not have this extra tempo later
rook c8 b3
now I have all my pawns defended and
actually I calculated this that rook
takes d5 doesn't really work for him
because obviously C takes he would have
looked c1 and this would be annoying
this would be pretty annoying but I can
take with my queen takes takes rook c1
and when he tried to do the same thing i
checkmate him
but the same pattern so there's no
tricks for him Queen c7 Castle g6 and
all of my pieces are pretty well placed
so there's b5 defy my pawn my pawns I'm
happy with but there are other pieces I
need to activate how can i or how should
i activate my pieces in this position
yeah Queen to wear green g4 well if you
go to g4 you're moving on the side very
black is playing black wants to play on
the King King side
if you go clean dieter I take you Queen
a one yes what's the idea behind the
king an a.1 yeah I have a firm grip on
the a file now and also I want to
exchange of this only good defensive
piece on c8 Bishop d2 queen a3 well I'm
not I'm not happy with the idea of
Bishop before so I'm gonna stop that
first Knight f5 rook c6 takes takes b6
and now there's not enough defenders for
black to stop me from promoting this
pawn as the only defender here is the
bishop which is still kind of far away
it should be by should be on c5 by now
efore okay one just bringing some more
fuel queenie 8 takes takes it's a check
that's important otherwise e 2 might be
a threat King g7 now I calmly stop this
idea with King F 1 he takes F 2 and how
can I wrap this game up yeah
b7 and a bishop e1
yeah
if kinky - I have 93 and I promote my
cream so even in winning positions you
have to be careful
well yes rook e8 yes and after rookie
and my opponent resigned as I'm just
defending against his only threat only
threat of 93 jump if 93 I just take it
and and I just queen
so in these middle game positions it's
still possible to create past bonds and
in fact you should aim to create past
bonds as it will be useful in the
endgame just like in the game I played
against name at so my second game was
played against Daniel narrowed its key
its it was played in DC Washington well
it wasn't played in who given that's a
glitch efore e6 d4 d5 Knight c3 Bishop
b4 b5 this is a classical French win
over line that we played actually
Meredith he played this against Corona
and the u.s. championship think months
before takes takes Queen a5 Bishop d2
Queen a4 in fact the screen a4 idea
which is trying to kind of stop this d2
Bishop to from activating was
popularized by the famous Hungarian
Grandmaster portage so I play it Queen
b1 now karana played queen g4 which
could be better but both is playable the
old main line is actually Queen B one
that I played c4 and now a strategic
battle will ensue h4 I'm trying to ramp
up my pawn with h4 h5 h6 Knight c6h5
Bishop d7 but he doesn't seem to be too
bothered about that Queen B - gasps age
six G three castles will be one now this
Queen B - rugby one plan might seem a
bit weird but my point is in some
variations black is aiming to bring the
rook up on the Queen side so I'm
stopping that for
good will be1 b69 of 397 Bishop g2 rook
f8
he's clearly preparing the idea of f6
Bishop f4 I'm getting ready for that to
happen
King b7 but yes Timon it's a slow
strategic position green c1 we're kind
of playing against or for the idea of f6
and trying to stop it with my queen
and Bishop and he's trying to get ready
to play it anyways Bishop e8 a very good
move getting ready to hit on h5 whenever
the position opens up g4 I defend
against that f6 he takes up 6g takes f6
Bishop d6 rogue g8 Bishop h3 f5 I have a
feeling that even though black is fine
f5 seems to be a bit too aggressive but
that's my opinion of this position
Bishop e7 F takes G for Bishop f6 so
that's an intermediate move as I will
unfortunately lose one of these pieces
but I want to create the situation
that's most favorable for me route 8 7
and now I use this tactical movement to
create a passed pawn for myself which
will be actually pivotal in the later
part of the game so it's a white to move
and can create a path bomb and it's
white to move to create a passed pawn in
this position yeah
mmm-hmm Knight g5 so the idea is that
I'm going to lose the piece back I'm
just up a piece temporarily so I want to
create something for for its own ig5
interestings g5 Bishop takes g4 and now
I at least have a healthy h5 pawn rook
f8 Bishop takes G v e5 this should be
three takes takes and now Nora did skip
plays or move that looks very tempting
but I think it's a bit too early it's
actually the black to move and if he had
played this move he would have good play
here
what should black play in this position
obviously my main weaknesses are my
pawns pawn on d4 c2 and a little bit on
h5 as well even though I am protecting
it for the moment yeah c3 that's what he
played the move is actually bishop g6
what she should have played I can't take
because of the back rank check and I
lose everything and otherwise I'll have
to make some awkward moves even though
I'm a pawn up as this threat of Bishop
take c2 is quite strong
she played c3 and here I played a strong
move Queen d1 and I'm not really
concerned with the a3 pawn I really want
to defend these pawns on d4 and h5
mostly so he did play Bishop g6 but now
I have a very comfortable defensive move
which is very natural in this Vanara
structures yes
rook b3 indeed and now the black Queen
is cut off and I'm left with this very
strong passer on h5 Bishop b4 a3 rookie
7
you know he thought that he has very
good pressure if I take on e4 rook takes
e4 and that would indeed be pretty
dangerous but I played something that
you don't don't usually play on move 32
yeah 86 well no I didn't play that one
in fact i castled which is quite rare on
move 32 and he missed this idea the
problem here for Black now that he's
running out of counter play and I'm
still left with this extra h5 pawn
Bishop f5 rook takes c3 Knight a5 Bishop
g5 book f7 but he didn't give up and
came up with this pretty good plan of
coming with the Knight to c4 trying to
have some ghost threats on d2 or e3
Bishop f5 will get 5 f4 so whenever
you're up upon and you feel that you
have the advantage and have a better
pass pawn try to exchange some pieces
Queen d7 h6
now I defend both of these spawns and I
should be comfortably better here Knight
c4 Queen age 592 rookie 194 rookie three
Queen c7 now nowadays he managed to
conjure up some play here so now I'm at
a crossroad this night is extremely
strong on e4 threatening ideas of Knight
takes g5 and even sometimes rook takes
g5 and Queen g3 ideas might work so I
have to come up with a good move here
it's white to move
and take the initiative
you're insane yeah yeah rook takes c4 of
course so the idea is I'm trying to
remove your only very aggressive piece
left and hoping to use my pawns on h6
which are pretty menacing and f4 to full
effect
d takes c4 Luke takes c4 mean take c2
now I didn't see mates in this position
and I don't think that I can make yet
because the screen is just too far away
so I played Queen e2 as the endgame
should be favorable to me you know disk
you seem to agree with that I'm played
you can see six but he still should have
taken and it's not necessarily that easy
to win this position although White's
plan is quite easy to go up King G to
king g4 and try to nurse that pawn into
cleaning so clean c6 root k7 check King
B 887 if you have a passport push that
off push that pass pawn rook b5 and now
black is threatening with this rugby one
ideas so I need to come up with a good
plan to parry that how can I parry that
idea of rugby Mon and rook h1 check yeah
Queen e1 then you invite my opponent to
go to rugby too and then we get to
passive you don't want to get to passive
because my King is a bit area at the
moment
Queeny six he could still go rugby one
check so so I decided to go with a
prophylactic move of moving away
immediately because if he goes
rugby one then I can give a check and
play Queenie four and I don't have to
bother with these rugby one ideas
anymore
at the moment I don't really have this
idea of Queenie five check because the
rook takes away that square so rook c8
was played rook g7 now my simple plan is
to play VOC g8 rugby three rook g8 rugby
one and after Queen g2 I'm stopping all
of his ideas and after Queenie six rook
takes Queen take see it as otherwise I
just queen I play Bishop f6 and he
resigned as there's no way to stop this
h-bomb from promoting so in general I
was majorly helped but with the idea of
creating a passed pawn in the middle
game and that helped me to win this
complicated game against our debts key
my second game I my third game that my
third game that I want to show is played
against a go potty and the middle part
is not as important I'm just skipping
through that one this is the critical
position now this position is fairly
equal and there's not much going on but
it's kind of a dull kind of equal why
can't push and I will eventually play
Knight e5 to put some slight pressure on
this solid but passive pawn structure
Bishop b4 95 takes takes 97 Bishop g3t
takes b takes e5 now if I've is a very
creative
dear here that was played by my opponent
but I had no choice I have to accept
that pawn sacrifice takes takes rook e8
now if you want to prove that your
position is sound you have to take
sacrifices time after time so in this
position how can I be stingy and keep to
my pond and keep my pawn advantage yeah
F for this does look ugly but there's no
other way I could keep my pawn
I mean d6 Queen e2 just sticking to my
palm f6 and now I come up with a very
nice positional idea in some ways it's a
sacrifice soon yeah 94 so the idea is
that I'm willing to part with my pawn
advantage but for that I'll get an
eternal knight on e4 so I played c5
Queen c7 and now I had a dilemma there's
two moves here what would be the first
move that pops into our brain pops into
mind
yeah 96 now that was obviously my first
thought my d6 was my first thought but
then I realized that takes takes and
indeed I win an exchange but this Bishop
is just crippling my rooks and it
constantly threaten this Bishop takes c5
mean why my rooks are kind of passive so
I decided that this is not sure if I'm
much better here so instead I played f5
and I'm kind of proud of this move
because this move creates a pseudo pass
pawn which will eventually lead to the
downfall of my opponent and instead of
being up in a complicated position and
having an exchange advantage I chose to
have a majority on the kingside rook f8
rook F 1 I'm kind of planning and
preparing this idea of f6 rook the 8-pin
g4 Bishop d2 very nice little trick by
my opponent trying to just create some
this like a little bit of
disorganization in my position so I
decided that I'll go back and I'll stop
this idea of Bishop d2 for good now my
opponent didn't feel it at in this
position yet but this f1 has invaders
seen as invader zim would say will cause
him to have a doomed position so f6 in
Dida I played that Queen d7 in rook f1 I
felt that I need an extra piece to help
me in the attack he didn't take on c5
because of this simple takes and I have
these Knight f6 ideas which are pretty
hard to parry
he played g6 and now I need to come up
with an idea how to continue so why to
move and get an advantage with that very
strong f6 pawn yeah if you play 96 I
take on c5
in general your past bond is the
strongest if you push it yeah
f7 King g7 and how should I continue
here Knight f6 yes
fini six and again I was faced with the
choice of taking on d5 we're doing
something else but I just spotted
something unusual night eh check that
that's what I played if he goes King
gate seven I can go rook f6 and an
eventual queen g4 our Queen c2 would win
the game because there's no one who
could stop me from taking on g6 so he
decided to take on the 8th and here I
came up with a pretty nice idea to my to
move and win
it's a rare tactical idea that I found
in this position yeah I have takes it I
would just take back and there I'm not
sure if I'm winning so it's not f2x e8
yes
Queen f3 then I move my rook yeah rook
f6 that's the other solution I played
queen g4 because if Queen takes g4 I
have a very nice solution here
it's my to move on then yeah
you have to put a piece there I have to
take c8 what night yes F take c8 night
and surprisingly I checked me very nice
checkmate there now
he played Queen East seven
if he goes rook dd8
I have a very simple solution here yeah
yeah
rook f6 I take your queen
be careful yeah come again
if you take the Queen I take and you
just only want an exchange you can when
bigger here go bigger if you can
yeah just promote queen and takes and
then I win the Queen and obviously it's
never too late to lose so here is so you
should take and then you just a queen up
so so you play it queen e7 and I played
blue cap six now now again there's no
Queen f6 because I have to take C eight
nights and them it's a double attack so
he played g5 and I was heavily relying
again on the f7 point and played Queen
h5 again and then this position Luke h8
I have a very very pretty mate that I
can give ya queen g6 I play King f8
rook g6 check so King can't go to h7 can
go here because I made so black is
forced to go to f8 yeah yeah Queen takes
eight-six rook takes and Queen g g8 mate
so this shows how powerful it can become
a past one can become very powerful if
you promote it and push it as far as the
seventh rank so it's very important to
support it but rooks like I did like I
did in this game this heavy artillery
was a good support for my pawn and that
way I could come up with this very nice
screen sacrifice with Queen g4 unless
but not least I want to show this game
which actually was a Daboo for both
Winnick against capablanca and with this
win he became a real contender for the
World Championship title so here how
should we continue with white obviously
we're a pawn down so we have to rush
with him attack yeah f4 of course F for
now f5 is a huge threat so Capablanca as
natural genius he was knew that he has
to stop that for ever but obviously both
Winnick took on poisson correct knight
takes f6 f5 and if you're under attack
there's a rule you could follow and you
should follow what you should do when
your opponent is attacking
counter-attack or exchange some pieces
and that's what couple Blanca does takes
on e1
look take c1 rook e8 but now both
Winnick comes up with a very powerful
move I mean actually this move is the
clincher if it weren't for this move
what Winnick would have had a tough time
yeah rookie six rookie six and now rook
takes f6 is threatened and Capablanca is
basically forced to take F takes c6 and
voila
open Oh voila there's our past bond
we've been dreaming of in the middle
game so Queenie King g7 Queen f4 just
coming closer and also trying to pin the
king queen e8 Queenie five Queen e7 and
what Rennick finds a very spectacular
move
try to move and get the initiative did
you raise your hand no did you stretch
that's good stretching is healthy hint
but vinick's idea would be labeled as
removing an important defender yeah
Bishop a3 yes X plans everywhere
so if the Queen moves we'll just start
pushing the pawn and that will be the
end of it so capablanca took or should
we continue yes
if a seven the King moves we have seven
and it's not over yet
yeah
yeah yes not Age 5
yeah check takes
between g5 yeah so the King has very few
places to go King f8 in takes f6 the
King goes to g8 as he eight runs into
the idea of Queen f7 Queen d7 checkmate
so King g8 if Queen f7 I go to h8 e 7
that's it he's 7 and now kappa blanka is
in huge trouble as not only this pawn is
threatening to promote what Queen f8 is
also made so e 7 Queen c1 check here in
c2 game g3 and what Vinick is just
running away with the King King takes h5
and sadly for capablanca Queen g6
doesn't even work because I take take
King takes g6 and the lone King stops
you from ever entering this f7 square
and the pontius promotes so
so after a few checks
Queeny to check England creamy to check
engage to be 4g for guinea one check
engage five and Capablanca resigned
there's no more checks and there's no
way that can stop the Queen f8 and this
pawn from promoting so that's the way to
use your passports in the middle games
and I hope that you learned a valuable
lesson from these examples thank you
[Music]